c'est en affichant la prise en compte de
la mission des enseignants que le
recteur a évoqué sa volonté de
finalement maintenir des heures dédiées
aux établissements du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire plus ça va se traduire par
le rétablissement d'une partie de
majeure partie de moyens qui auraient dû
être supprimés depuis 2015 qu'ils ont
été d'ailleurs dans beaucoup d'académies
donc nous les maintenant en partie pour
pouvoir montrer dans le cadre de
l'évaluation des établissements qui va
se mettre en place qu'ils sont utiles au
niveau d'heure qui permettrait donc
selon le recteur de mieux évaluer les
moyens nécessaires pour les prochaines
rentrées
je souhaiterais faire de l'évaluation et
de particulièrement de l'auto évaluation
par les acteurs eux-mêmes une sorte de
laboratoire qui permettra de prouver
mieux à ceux qui en douteraient que ses
moyens sont nécessaires parce qu'il se
traduise par des résultats en hausse
chez les élèves au collège diderot à
besançon et ce mardi au collège
anatole-france de béthoncourt elle ou
blazer de montbéliard enseignants et
parents d'élèves avaient exprimé leur
colère pour le snes fsu le geste du
recteur est loin d'être suffisant pour
mémoire 150 heures par semaine en moins
sur diderot 75 heures en moins sur
voltaire 80 heures en moins sur le lycée
victor hugo c'est absolument énorme et
le recteur en réinjectant une vingtaine
d'heures par rapport à tout ce qui a été
ponctionné ne fait jamais essayé
d'éteindre l'incendié
en outre pour le syndicat le réseau rêve
plus est incomplet
il n'est pas pensée de l'école primaire
jusqu'au lycée puisque aucun lycée n'en
fait partie et toutes les écoles
primaires n'en font pas partie alors
même qu'elle scolarise des élèves qui
sont dans des situations comparables à
ceux qui sont dedans
la manifestation prévue dans le quartier
planoise en fin d'après midi a été
maintenue